all right Sophia hi Sophia where did you
grow up where are you from originally um
I'm from Milwaukee
Wisconsin um and I lived there my whole
life and I just moved to Washington DC
about three months ago oh welcome to the
east coast thank you tell me about your
family growing up you had both your
parents yes um which I'm very thankful
for um my dad was a police officer
growing up and he um he was never home
during the well he was home during the
day but he was always asleep um because
he worked night shift and so I never
really saw him growing up until he quit
which was when I was around
10 um and my mom during that time was
pretty much like a a a single mom um she
worked a 9 to-5
and um she's definitely like probably
the strongest woman that I know um I
don't know how she does it um you had
you had siblings yeah yeah me and my
younger sister um she's 18 months
younger than me so yeah it's like
raising two little toddlers during that
how would you describe your childhood in
general um I'd say my I'd say it was
really good honestly my childhood was
awesome my teenage
years um that complete different story
um ever since I was like 12 or 13 um
that's when things became really
difficult but before
then um I my parents made it made my
childhood so wonderful I grew up in a
really rich neighborhood and I went to
the number one school in the state which
would later bite me in the ass but
um yeah how old are you now I'm 19
you're 19 mhm so you graduated high
school yes well actually I didn't I I
say that because I'm so used to saying
that um no I I dropped out um so when
I okay so high school at first was great
um I was a straight A student 4.0 GPA
that was freshman year and then Co hit
and sophomore
year um was bad and it just got worse
and worse to the point I think I only
did half of junior year um I still
completed junior year but I only did
half of it um the other half I was
either in partial
hospitalization therapy intensive
outpatient therapy or inpatient
therapy um because of how bad my mental
health was from a lot of um factors like
um I was
being um oops I was being abused um
emotionally uh by several people in my
life and and I was super hard on myself
when it came
to um when it came to school
work and that just
became um almost like unbearable for me
and by the time I
was um a senior I I didn't even go into
school and I said I'm done like why do
you think you were having these mental
problems um so it all started when I was
I'd say
12 um I was it's always like an outside
factor and now I think my brain's my
brain is kind of like used to it
so basically sixth grade I was bullied
and in seventh grade I was fine eighth
grade my mom was diagnosed with
cancer and so that was tough and then
ninth grade it was fine and sophomore
year uh Co started and that was by far
the
worst um outside Factor you know um that
was yeah that was probably the hardest
thing just being a teenager is tough
anyway yeah yeah um and I I went into
high school
with five best friends we were all so
close I had like I said before straight
A and everything
um and I came out with no friends at all
um super
depressed um I was almost failing all my
classes I didn't fail one actually but
like the lowest I got was like a D minus
so I was like pretty close um so yeah do
you think this is some brain chemistry
thing that you just had naturally or or
is it something outside that caused it I
think I think um I've inherited it
through someone someone my um my dad has
really bad ADHD and
anxiety um my and depression especially
my mom has really bad anxiety and I just
happen to get all of that um my sister
um of course I I haven't really like
talked to her deeply about this but she
doesn't um seem to have those issues and
if she does she hides them really well
um so yeah sometimes it's just the luck
of the draw that you you ended up
picking up
these probably inherited traits and and
she didn't yeah maybe she's more
resilient or something but I'm sure you
have other qualities that are great that
come with these shortcomings right yeah
um what are your strongest what are your
best
qualities um it's always so hard to
answer I'd say you're a great
communicator thank you um I one thing
I'm I'm always eager to
learn um even though I did so poorly in
school um I
never try to waste my time whenever
there's a new opportunity to learn um I
love
history so much I love
philosophy I just have this huge
bookshelf I think I have 20
books just on George Washington Alone
um
and yeah but it's it's hard coming up
with those good qualities
when people your entire life or at least
the teenage years um you know said quite
the
opposite um even like family
members you know
so are there things that you want to do
with your life do you have dreams of
Direction you like to go in yeah I would
like
to um do something with
activism or political science um you're
in the right City yeah exactly that's
that's why I moved I um I knew that I
had to get my
GED and it's kind of interesting how I
moved because my my
dad and I don't get along very well um
he can be like I know he loves me and I
love him but sometimes he can be
um what my what several doctors and
therapists have said like emotionally
abusive and I um you know with
that
um you know it's it made me feel really
suicidal one day and I was like I have
to get out of here like I don't know
what to do and
um I've tried to
um commit suicide at
least three or four times um just
between 17 and 18 and um you know my dad
made me feel so poorly where I was like
I have to move out and I may as well if
I'm moving out I may as well move out to
a city where I can like
pursue my goals and stuff so
so yeah so basically is that why you
left home yeah and U my mom said I'm not
going to help you at all until you get
your
GED so I got my GED the day before I
left and I didn't even tell my dad I was
leaving I think I told him like 2 days
before like oh yeah by the way just sign
the lease so you're in DC now and you're
on your own I have three rooms roommates
currently one roommate
is I tried it's funny I tried to
escape um
narcissism and I went right back into it
with one of my
roommates um so I just um signed the
lease today actually for a new apartment
um someone's taking over my current
lease and my new apartment is a studio
um I'm so I'm so
thankful that I can have my own place um
it's obviously not the best place ever
cuz I I don't have a lot of money um but
you won't have that energy around you
that you're going to have to deal with
yeah I rather work 50 hours a week than
having to deal with that um and work is
is so
hard it
it's nearly impossible um cuz I'm still
severely depressed
and um going to
work it's hard to even you know just
like get up out of bed and obviously you
know a lot of people don't understand
mental health and so um my boss would
always be
like well this is the last time like
this is the last time I'm going to like
hear this excuse and I was like okay
well last time I literally was in the
hospital because of you know really bad
anxiety and a huge panic attack and um
they just don't
understand um like literally no one
understands which is so irritating were
the suicide attempts your darkest
point he must have been that's a good
question um I
think probably yeah I think those were
also just kind of like spur in the
moment um cuz I feel like my whenever I
think of like my darkest
times it was just being alone just
having a panic attack crying in my
bedroom and my parents would hear me
just like cuz I couldn't help like when
I have a panic attack I can't help like
literally screaming in agony and my
parents rushed into my room and they
literally had to pin me to the ground
because I couldn't like they were scared
I was going to get up and um find a
knife and cut myself and do self harm
again
um so I think I still
have I still have um seven cuts on my
legs right here from 2 years ago and
they're still there from cutting mhm
yeah have you been diagnosed with like
anything yeah um I've been diagnosed
with
depression um I think when I was like 12
anxiety when I was like three or four
and ADHD was the most recent that was
like a couple months
ago but not anything like borderline
person disorder or anything like that I
wouldn't be surprised if I have that um
but yeah I haven't I haven't been tested
for that at all um I've also
noticed like just throughout the years
it just gets worse and worse um and I
I'm at that point where I literally like
I don't know what to do about it anymore
and I'm thinking of like if there's like
some sort of surgery that you could get
like I'm down cuz like I just I can't do
it anymore and it's um even
the like these mental health problems
cause a lot of physical problems too um
I faint a lot from it's called
pots and it's like whenever I stand up I
just bam I'm on the floor
so I uh I recently interviewed a woman
who is a couple years older than you I
think mhm and she was dealing with
depression severe
depression uh gwendaline was her name I
I interviewed her like a month ago and
she was using trans cranial magnetic
stimulation which yeah which kind of
stimulates parts of your brain that are
not very active and and kind of gets
blood flow or gets activity to that area
it seems
and it basically solv her depression
like yeah within a month and a half yeah
that's my mom is currently looking into
that yeah I think that that's a really
interesting
yeah possibility for you
mhm do do you feel misunderstood
by like your family and most people
Everyone um there's
only two people in my life that I
know um that really understand well I'd
say three and that is my current
two best friends Bridget and
Sonia and um my
mom um
family um I I think they're getting
better at understanding um my ex best
friends oh my God that was so bad um
I I was they literally stopped talking
to me cuz I was going to
therapy
um and just like ignored me all the time
and um then eventually like I finally
like lost it after like 5 months like
why are you guys treating me like this
and then you know
they'll like why are you freaking out
like why are you like what's wrong with
you like you know you're crazy and um so
yeah it's just
like and I don't think they're bad
people I think it's just the lack
of
understanding what do you think would be
the most helpful thing that people could
do to help people like yourself um like
this I think it's about what they do but
I think it's about what they don't do um
one
thing people say this so much and it's
like treat others the way that you want
to be treated and like I know everyone
says that um but I
think because you never know what is
going on in someone else's life or how
they're going to um interpret like how
like what you said for an example when I
was 14 my sister was 12 I think we we
had to go to the bathroom and we were at
the mall and we went in and the Stalls
were you couldn't see like the floor
like it was like a door for the Stalls
and it said open so we opened it because
like my sister wanted to use the
bathroom and this woman who didn't even
lock the door was like get out you
little
[__] and um my poor sister
like she was so young and like she's
never been called that before and I like
it was just kind of like a hard you know
hard like hearing that and little did we
little did that woman know was that less
than an hour later that's when we found
out our mom had cancer and I'm like I
just
I don't understand like even if people
could walk around and be like assume
what's going on in somebody's life like
just like even if it's made up like oh
yeah her mom just died so be nice to her
like if there's any way people can do
that
because people like I get like people
are stressed but they're so they're so
mean to others
and um I think that's the worst
factor in mental health is like when
you're not understood but also when
people are
just like cruel yeah
mhm
yeah what would you say is your biggest
regret so
far
um
so there was this um guy in high school
who um had a crush show me uh he was his
expectations were pretty low um but
I I was just not I was not into it at
all and normally I would just be like no
sorry like I'm not interested but I
can't even remember how I dealt with it
cuz that whole time period in my life
was such a blur and I I dealt with it so
poorly cuz I wasn't used to anybody
having all of their attention on me and
um I was pretty shitty to him
and eventually I I called them up um and
I apologized and he was like I just feel
bad cuz he's been bullied a lot and I
think he just you know was
like well thanks for the apology but
also [__] you you know um I'd say that
was my biggest regret I've also had
other things in my life but I I realize
that um those stem from trying to deal
with trauma like when my grandfather
passed away when I was seven um he was
cuz my dad was wasn't home during that
time he was like my other dad he was
like my second dad I was so close to him
and when he died um
I just would go around school like
laughing about it like I would joke
about it with my friends and I could
never forgive myself for that until I
realize like oh no that's that's how I
process my pain is through humor and
joking around and um a lot of people do
that yeah yeah and that's something that
took me years to figure
out so I think that's a very healthy way
of dealing with stuff like that yeah
yeah um cuz people are always telling me
like you are seriously like the funniest
person I know and I'm
like I'm like okay well that's good like
I'm I'm hiding it well but you feel you
feel like you're getting worse than not
getting better yeah really mhm um and
psych medications are I take seven
different meds you do yeah wow
and um constantly like they're changing
it all the time and it's so irritating
um because here in in America
you um if the meds aren't working you
have to set up a med appointment
and I mean the earliest you can get into
that appointment would be like 3 months
like oh God and I remember telling my
mom like I can't I can't do this for
another 3 months and and sure enough I
literally couldn't and then I tried to
kill myself so they put me
into um an inpatient hospital and that's
I guess the one good thing about being
inpatient was that you have access
to um psychiatrists all the
time so they're like okay we'll change
your meds and we'll make sure like
you're all good and you know we'll
evaluate you and
stuff
do you have hope that one day you'll be
free from from
this yeah I do um
I was just on FaceTime with my mom two
days ago and I was just crying about it
cuz I was like it's already robbed me of
so much it I couldn't graduate high
school um I had to I was
like I lost
so many friends because of it um
and I even like I couldn't even stay at
my house anymore because it was yeah it
was my like my dad and I didn't get
along but even just being in that old
room that you know having all those
memories
constantly coming back to like oh in
that corner I cut myself and I did the
first time in that corner and and
upstairs that's where I was looking for
pills to end my life and um after living
there I'm like I literally can't can't
live here anymore cuz it just like it
brings back so many terrible memories
and even walking into my high school um
my old high school I I couldn't do that
anymore are you happier now living on
your own oh yeah than you were at home
with your parents
yeah um it's I think what's made me the
most happy
is um living in DC because I've always
wanted to live in DC and it's honestly
such a dream come true
and
um I didn't have that back in
Wisconsin and I want to you know I want
to get more into politics and um and I
feel like Wisconsin kind of offered me
as many things as it could like I was
canvasing cuz I guess like a good thing
about dropping out of high school was
that I would have had that political
experience of speaking to so many people
of different backgrounds and different
ages about like the importance of voting
and stuff and um um it's not even like
it wasn't about like whether you're
republican or democrat or in between or
neither like it wasn't about that it was
just about like coming together as like
a community and creating change
and that was it was a pain in the ass
cuz I was in Milwaukee which isn't the
best area knocking on
doors and you know people would slam
their doors and someone
um threaten somebody else with a gun
like but it was just it was nice to like
have that
experience what's worse your depression
or your
anxiety
um I think I think they're um pretty
much
equal but to be honest I'm glad that
they're equal because I feel like one
prevents
the other one taking
over um I a good way to explain this is
my like
depression is so bad where I I just want
to die every single day but my anxiety
won't let me because I'm too scared how
do you if you if you do make an
attempt on your life how do you you
typically go about doing that
so
the first
time was like planned out I wrote a
letter um to everybody I took all my
jewelry I put it all in separate boxes
like this is for my mom this is for my
sister this is for my friend and and
then um I went to school cuz normally my
parents would literally have to drag me
out of the house and like you're going
to school and this time I went willingly
and they're like okay this is weird so I
went to the school and the school's
right next to Lake
Michigan and um my mom dropped me off
and I was already late and I knew that I
wasn't going to be on time and I walked
I was walking through the
building and I was just like sobbing but
I was so
quiet
and to the right of me I could see this
um this girl just like running like
panting because she was late to her
class like and just didn't even like
notice me and I'm like God I wish I had
that problem and I walked straight
through the
building and straight to the lake and I
was going to jump in but I it was it was
cold it was like December or something
but I couldn't I just couldn't make
myself do it
and um and then I looked at my phone and
there was like several Miss calls from
my mom just like crying
like like where are you where' you go
because the school couldn't find me and
they basically locked down the entire
school and the teachers were going
through like all the rooms all the
bathrooms trying to find me and so they
called up my parents and my parents were
driving around town um trying to find me
so it's a it's a frustrating problem
because it's not you know Common Sense
and a pep talk won't really help you
will it yeah and people as many times as
I've one thing I'm really good at is
reaching out for help and I would talk
to somebody about it and they'll be
like oh okay
well um how about you just go home and
I'm like well I want to stay here at
school because because it's safer for me
here and they're like well you're
suicidal so you should go home and I'm
like yeah but there's pills there
there's a gun there and they're like
well you should just go home and I'm
like what and then then you know it
doesn't it doesn't hit them about like
how bad it is until um until I try to
commit suicide and then they're like oh
like okay now we get how bad it is and
I'm like it shouldn't have to go to that
point for people to realize how bad it
is do you feel like most people don't
understand or don't don't take it
seriously yeah I don't think
people understand how bad it
is um at all I think they're like well
like my grandma was like I'll just take
a walk you know I'm like that's not
going to do anything like I take walks
every day to clear my mind and
um yeah it it's no matter what you do it
it's just like impossible
to to get rid of and maybe it's not but
for now
when you talk to a medical professional
and they're like okay so we can offer
you three things we can do IOP and I was
like I did that three times okay how
about partial hospitalization did that
twice okay how about you go impatient
did that last time and some guy asked me
for sex in the
hospital and they red me with this
50-year-old this poor woman she was very
schizophrenic um but she would like
scream at me and be like you're going to
rot in and burn in hell
and I'm like I can't I just can't do
that again like how is this going to
help me you
know what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned Sophia in
your life um so I
think just seeing
how um precious life is because CU When
I was at my lowest
moment my one of my best friends got
sepsis
and she was so close to
death and um I couldn't visit her in the
hospital cuz that was during Co but um
she
was oh my God she was like
unrecognizable and I was thinking like
okay this isn't fair
because like she loves like she's the
most like kindest person I know and she
has to leave but I'm the one who doesn't
even want life anymore and I have to
stay here and um I like this is kind of
like unfair
but um I've had like you know I haven't
had a lot of death in my life but I've
had like significant death in my life
and every time I see it I'm
like like no I can't like I can't like
they didn't have a choice but I do you
know and I would always feel guilty
about
that all right Sophia thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you I hope
you figure out a
solution yeah me too the TMS sounds
really interesting yeah
that's the most interesting thing I've
heard on on these kind of things mhm all
right thank you very much thank
you